you
[Music]
today I'm actually going to be talking a
little bit about embeddings and about
pre-training your own embeddings these
is going to be very practical in terms
of its approach and it's sort of the
talk that I would have loved to have
heard about a year ago and so I'm going
to be talking a lot more about the
practice than a lot of the math behind
the embeddings and I'm specifically
going to be talking about exponential
family but embeddings which are a method
that was developed by a lab actually
here at Columbia I'm David blaze lab and
how we found them to be actually an
interesting set of algorithms and models
for the sort of questions that we have
to ask and I think that they have a lot
of very interesting potentials for
industrial applications so things like
recommendation systems and things like
that but a bit of background about us so
we are a startup and we're based sort of
in the human resources area and we're
specifically right now focused on
looking at job descriptions and helping
employers write much better job
descriptions that attract a broad
candidate pool and so we do this through
three major mechanisms and so we're
essentially the idea behind our mission
is to sort of bring data into people
analytics and the first major mechanism
and the first product that we've
commercialized is a smart editor for job
descriptions which I'll show you on the
next slide and essentially what it does
is it breaks down a Job Description into
the language into the skills that it's
talking about and tries to suggest make
suggestions based on what we know works
in terms of attracting different types
of jobseekers and what we know that
doesn't work that seems to act as
barriers to candidates the second major
mechanism we have is a pipeline health
modeling monitoring which is an
analytics dashboard and essentially what
that does is it looks through your
talent pipeline and tries to identify
areas where you might be not acting very
fairly and there's a bit of bias
creeping in and the third area is in
terms of salary estimation and
essentially salary estimation is our
sort of one of the many levers that we
pull a job on people who are writing job
descriptions to not ask for Unicorn
candidates so if we are asking for
someone who's a star data engineer and a
star data
scientists and style machine learning
engineer and we estimate that that
salary is something like three hundred
thousand usually an employer is going to
back off and be like actually my my you
know my budget is probably close to a
hundred and so we've sort it's one of
the many levers we sort of used to talk
about that
so what's underpinned by this is a whole
lot of data on job descriptions we have
millions of salary salaries for and
which we've broken down by skills and
requirements and essentially it sort of
all works in this context so that we've
just sort of gives you a visual of the
front of the interaction that you have
we have obviously very specific language
and content suggestions and so this is I
mean we're essentially very much a very
strong natural language processing tool
which uses a lot of AI and behavioral
science and our back-end and okay can I
talk about next so the what I find
really fascinating about job
descriptions is that the importance of
language and job descriptions and we're
very interested in how that language
plays out in terms of outcomes but a lot
of what I find interesting is that a lot
of the current thinking in terms of job
descriptions tends to take one or two
aspects of a job description and impute
things so in a lot of company a lot of
algorithms look at the title of a job
and consider that the most important
component and when you look at these
jobs and you break down the skills and
the requirements what you find is that
these are actually quite different jobs
a Finance Manager at a sort of consumer
production CPG can use humor produced
community groups company is very
different to one which is obviously
something more of a finance skill rather
than someone who is much more than a
manager in a sort of more junior role
and the same thing can happen and this
sort of underpins a lot of our work is
that we're able to by being able to
parse the convert that sort of
unstructured natural language data into
specific skills were able to find apples
to apples comparisons between jobs that
on the
if you look at the titles or if you look
at other aspects of them they're not
very obviously comparable and we're able
to do this not only in terms of skills
but to sort of compute things like you
know even if even if a job doesn't
mention sequel we can extract the you
know relational database experience is
likely to imply that and we do this
through a wide variety of different NLP
tools and so understanding and
extracting skills and and content and
requirements from jobs is actually very
interesting for me area because it
allows us to in comparing these two jobs
allows us to get a lot more
signal-to-noise in all of the
predictions that we make so the question
that is the sort of focus of the topic
today is that that I'm going to present
to you guys of some of the research that
we do is how of data science skills
changed over time and we're talking
about time is from 2016 to 2018 because
sidebar a company pivoted in 2018 or
2017 and in 2016 we were a job search
site for two years and so we've been
amassing hundreds of millions of job
descriptions and so this is something
that we've always been very curious
about so I have a very large proprietary
data set of job descriptions so there
are a couple of different mechanisms
that we can use to identify changes
within data sets and these are sort of
very broad ones and they're sort of a
little historic and they're getting to
the newer point the first is manual
feature extraction and these are things
that I'm sure you're all familiar with
these a rule-based usually deterministic
mechanisms you can find a whole lot of
different ways of talking about sequel
and writing alternative ways of
extracting sequel relational database
experience and what the problem with
this sort of method is that it requires
you to select ahead of time what are the
key attributes and so and and to
identify all the different ways it's
actually spoken about in your corpus and
so it's actually very difficult to
identify new attributes or upcoming
attributes what you can do really well
with something like this is to figure
out things that you know probably that
you know are important that may be
weighed like it may be waning in sort of
importance but it's not so good for
finding what are the new cutting-edge
technologies a more recent sort of
mechanism or
more recent alternative but things like
dynamic topping models so these are
things that basically convert a document
into a bunch of bag of words and so each
document is represented by a whole set
of words and then we look at how they
fit into different models and how those
models change over time and again David
Blais lab who I'm gonna be referring to
a little bit later David Blaine himself
as a postdoc I think generated these
sorts of topic modeling and applied it
to a bunch of scientific and various
other forms of abstracts and corpuses of
abstracts and to see how like you know
the atomic physics has changed over time
one of the difficulties is for me I'm
sort of new at looking at atomic physics
that's not my background and if I look
at this set of lists of words or even
the top 20 list of words I can't really
extract what they talk about in terms of
these models and the wain in the ebb and
flow of their specificity so it does
require a little bit of intervention in
a way that requires a lot of sort of
knowledge so let's talk about wet
embedding word embeddings are sort of
the third approach and that we're going
to talk about and I'm specifically going
to talk about dynamic weight embeddings
but I wanted to get everyone up on the
same place in terms of wet embeddings
and so word embeddings are essentially a
distributional representation of the
meaning of words in the context of their
neighbors and so what we see here is for
example this if we wanted to wonder if
we wanted to understand a little bit
about Python and these are sort of some
example requirements from typical job
descriptions what we would see is that
we would take the word Python and then
look at its neighbors in terms of the
context of the words around it right and
these are actually and so so that's what
we would do for a word embedding model
and then we'd have sort of as in going
through this process we'd have a whole
bunch of words that would come up here
in terms of their proximity or Python
and how often they happened so again
what this abstracts away or converts
into is it takes a distribution of words
relative to their content their neighbor
and then creates distances so the closer
you are the more co-localize or more
close you are usually in terms of these
terms and the further you are the
further the less sort of similar you are
and then if we sort of add a broader
corporis and consider languages that you
know other sorts of languages what we
see is something like language gets
moved across and we have those sorts of
things and these have been really
embeddings have been extraordinary in
terms of catch in terms of what they've
been able to achieve in terms of
capturing for example entity
relationships between words and
different axes and so you can see that
this is a representation of a bunch of
companies of fortune 500 companies and
their CEOs and what I think is
fascinating is although the CEOs are
very strongly clustered the companies
you know you've got the media companies
clustering together and you've got the
like non media companies clustering
together and this is part of a bigger
data set from the Stanford and LPL of
project you understand these in terms of
superlatives and comparatives and so you
can understand the meaning if you didn't
understand what the meaning of strong
stronger and strongest was but you did
understand this you can sort of
interpret that or you could
theoretically impute from knowing this
what the words are the work in that same
dimension and then the last thing is and
this is probably what's taken people
most by the imagination is this idea
that by using these relationships we can
impute unknown sort of entities or
entities that we can impute an entity
that we're not super aware of and so
what typically happens though from these
sorts of processes and and what's made
this actually a really impressive and
very powerful technique is that that
we're able to so from going from
corporate generation to final
application we've got a whole bunch of
pre-trained models and at the
pre-trained embedding models basically
cut you through this whole process and
they're ready to go right now and you
can basically put them into your final
application and so you don't have to go
through these long-winded processes of
corpus generation
processing language model generation
what I wanted to highlight though is
that choosing which embedding model is
something that you should do with a lot
of care and I have experimented with all
of these different types of models and
what I will say is that you know
thinking about your final application is
very important picking a word embedding
model for example Wikipedia or Google
News which is a little less sentiment
focus and using it on a sentiment
analysis application is not going to
lead to very good results versus
something like the common Crowell which
is gonna be a lot more sentiment focused
and the other thing that I think is very
important is I have great respect for
the word Tyvek pre-trained embeddings
but I've actually found it very
difficult to reproduce those same
results and there is a lot of
instability or this you can call all
sorts of things with these models if
you're going to train them from scratch
using their exact conditions and so so
there is a bit of Socastee City and
these glove less so because it's not an
ER it's not neural focused in the same
way the other thing that I highlight
with these pre trained models is
particularly with the glove ones there
they have versions that are cased and
encased and this is actually important
for our application right it is a common
stock word that you frequently find you
know in most Awkward lists right and so
you remove it because you're like you
know these stock words happen too often
and they mess up meaning and things like
that but in our case what we find is if
you uncase it so if you have it if you
case it
we have IT IT is actually really
important for someone who works in job
descriptions and so we found that a lot
of the ways that casing and some of the
contexts and some of the pre-processing
of these models works is actually not
very great for some of the work that
we're doing and so it led us to this
sort of question of this problems with
the pre trained models and for you guys
it might not matter as much but these
were things that we sort of had to sort
of go through and realize the first is
of obviously abbreviations and words and
they matter you know differently
depending on what your application is
in terms of out of vocabulary words and
we actually found that to be quite
difficult so one of the beauties of job
descriptions but also the difficulties
of job descriptions is that they're very
incredibly domain focused and so they're
almost like trying to compare theses of
different disciplines a little bit and
so words that can mean something in some
contexts mean very different things in
other contexts and so we're also dealing
with the issues of domain specific words
that probably they don't come up in the
Google crawl I'm very frequently or not
in the format that it would in a common
sense the other sorts of areas that
we've had trouble with is in terms of
multi word expressions so phrases that
have new meanings so front-end is very
different to a front and end and
polysemy so these are words that have
multiple meanings and for us this is
important because chef is a job but it's
also a language and drive a car is very
different to drive results and we have
car driver jobs in our database that and
we have corporate jobs in our database
where these are actually play important
roles and so what ends up happening is
when you have words like this you you're
embedding sort of if you're using
pre-trained embeddings they won't
necessarily rough like this corpus and
some of the idiosyncrasies of your
corpus and so that's what I sort of
wanted to highlight as a key issue so
we've had to train our own embeddings
and part of this part of what I'm going
to be talking about are some of the
amazing tools that you can do that with
and some of the new technologies that
we've seen
so um corpus processing wise we use a
lot of space see we've basically created
our fork our own version of Spacey right
now because our own forms of dependency
passing and now I'm like it's in phrase
extraction and things like that that
Spacey does very well but there are a
couple of other obviously I would be
remiss to not talk about some of the
others the core NLP has had some recent
really impressive updates and syntax
note I think is the new name for
Google's past you might pass ways and
then on the other side of things in
terms of language modeling there's a
become very the thing that I love about
it it's a modular Alera T so you know we
use Spacey with various depending on
what the context is tends to flow or
Jensen back-end but these are great in
terms of they're very clean API
for language modeling they've all are
being optimized to a point where they're
running as fast as they possibly can
using you know the top numpy and pandas
implementations and I would route you
know when we you think about distributed
systems you know stage maker is probably
one of the better ones in terms of the
way that you would implement a language
model and there's something to consider
and so one of the things that I wanted
to talk about is in terms of the
parameter tuning so when you grow up
when you roll your own as you would say
in the word embedding space there's a
bunch of these sorts of tunings that are
actually really important what we find
is if we and this is again that toy
example that I showed you earlier when
we talked when we train with a small
window size what we find is that you
capture semantic similarities and these
are basically words that can substitute
versus when we train with a much larger
window size you get things like things
that would be a little bit further away
things like statistical modeling and
SPSS these are all going to clump a
little bit closer together with Python
and so these are going to be things that
are alternatives rather than substitutes
and I'll talk a little bit more about
alternatives and substitutes a little
bit later because actually that's
something that I think is really
interesting about this work so when we
trained our own embeddings well we've
done a bunch of tests this is one of the
few tests this is just an eye balled
test which is what most people do but
we've also done similarity tests and run
a bunch of other sorts of algorithms on
it you can see that the Equal
Opportunities language tends to cluster
together the perks language tends to
cluster together
obviously there's a lot more equal
opportunities and perks language these
are the top 500 words from our
embeddings just to firm from a t-sne
visualisation standpoint what we see is
that soft skills so things like problem
solving communication also cluster
together which I thought was really
interesting because I didn't expect them
to and because in the context of a job
description they typically are sort of
distributed throughout the job
description it's not always in a clean
chunk like you would expect with the
equal opportunities or the
affirmative a or the pecs language and
lastly in terms of just talking about
language about experience tends to
cluster together and maybe because we
have got a lot of finance roles that
seems to have come up in in this set but
in general that's that was sort of very
validating so that I mean I checked on
one way of evaluating embeddings there
are other sorts of ways in terms of
looking forward similarity and we have
those we've basically had to build those
algorithm we have to build those systems
too so that's one of the problems with
designing your own embeddings because
you can't take what's off-the-shelf and
assume that it's going to work for you
you have to build the test to see which
one is actually the best but if you do
an eye check and you you're okay with
something that I mean this is again a
distribution this is a princess so this
is a dimension reduction algorithm so
you're not going to see everything in
every dimension there are issues with
using this as your sole source but
that's something I can talk about later
so I have got three hundred actually
that one hundred and fifty two hundred
dimensions and but time isn't one so how
do we look at the time course of
embeddings and one of the mechanisms is
take create trainer as separate
embedding on each time course and then
stitch them together right and the
second one and this is actually done by
quite a few groups this is just a subset
of the groups that do this
the second major mechanism is to train
them all together and these both have
pros and cons and I'm going to focus on
the pros of this ones and the cons of
this one because this is what we're
using the first thing is in terms of
data hungriness I think this is a much
more data efficient algorithm and I'm
going to show you how we did it with
fifty thousand and five hundred thousand
job descriptions so that's quite small
by way of a corpus and we've been able
to extract some very interesting signals
and the second is that this requires
alignment so just because we have a
three hundred dimensional embedding in
each of the cases doesn't mean that you
could figure out where experiences in
this one and then map it to that one and
that it's going to be in the same place
you actually have to stitch this
experience to that experience and that
experience so you have to find the words
that are constant between them decide
what those are and then stitch them but
is that the dynamic embeddings which
don't actually require alignment what
happens is that we're assuming that
these are because they're trained
together even if you have sparsity say
2016 is a year that had fewer data
science jobs which actually didn't but
if it did and we have fewer words or say
our corpus half say our server went down
and we lost half of our corpus you can
still impute through that through that
process because when you're using some
of the statistical information from the
years before and the years after so the
implementation we used was as I
mentioned by David Blaise lab and that
is because the other two groups over
here did not actually publish or put
their repos anywhere that we could find
so two academic researchers if you put
your things out there someone will
actually use them and this is a repo
link that we use and basically what we
found and this is again results from
their paper so what they showed was
using Senate abstracts one of the
outputs that I think is very interesting
is the absolute drift so it what it does
is it just gives you a text file of all
of the words that show the most drift
and the second thing that it does is
that you can take a word and then find
the what neighbors of those words in
terms of find the neighbors of those
words so you know unemployment was one
of the top words here and you can see
how it changed from 1958 to being about
something a sort of about sort of moral
I guess in this case and then here we're
talking about alleviating it and then
we're talking about how it becomes a
very economic term in terms of forecasts
and joblessness and it's less of a moral
term so it sort of shows that
distinction one thing to remove a
hundred and forty years what we were
trying to do is map it over three years
which is you know quite a lot different
and so we've you know I it was kind of a
crazy project that we had and so I'm
going to show you how we did it and what
the results were um so again we did
those in time slices we're not actually
experimenting with breaking down the
time slices into a couple
time slices so you know like quarters or
a half years but initial experiments
were like sort of the number of
documents this just happened because we
had a streaming error at one point and
we couldn't get past the fifty Kamath
but we trained we've now gotten press
that obviously and they've got a much
larger corpuses and we're scaling up to
a five billion number of documents it
just takes a long time we need more
Amazon's
sort of a space to do this we restricted
the number of a cab the vocab size
that's partly because that's what the
original implementation did and in
general most of these embedding models
do restrict the number of the vocab size
and so what you end up doing is losing a
lot of unique words in our case I think
we were on the edge and so we're
actually going to experiment with that
and with data pre-processing we didn't
remove stock words we did very basic
data pre-processing so words like New
York were put together or New York City
was put together but outside of that it
was it was sort of very simple and very
straightforward and and that I think is
the biggest thing because this data
pre-processing process can take a long
time we did the minimal in terms of all
of that for those of you who are very
experienced with embeddings you'll see
that you know we trained embeddings with
100 dimensions it's partly because
that's what the group that published
this had most success with that's quite
small you know the word Tyvek embeddings
the 300 dimensions and so that's you
know quite an order like isn't quite
significantly bigger but actually what
we found with this was actually much
stronger results for whatever reason
okay so actual results first thing when
we trained with a small corpus what we
found was that in general we found gains
and losses in skills and and and losses
so I showed you that initial
documentation that said like the top
words that came out of it and one of the
top words that came out of it where PhD
is an MBA MBAs in our top ten words so
when we went back and looked at our
database we saw that actually in the
last four since 2016 to 2018 these are
the numbers and I'm going to show you
the number of jobs that require PhDs as
a relative number of jobs has dropped
and same thing with MBAs when we look in
data science jobs actually that effect
has been stronger and I know the people
probably who are job seekers don't feel
like this is actually happening but I
mean we've looked at we've looked across
the board like you think that machine
learning and deep learning is all on the
rise but actually we didn't see that and
we certainly saw that like the
requirements for PhDs are actually
getting lower oh yeah
and then the other thing so again blue
boxes are the phrases that were
indicated from the top drifting words
analysis the what we were surprised to
find I was expecting to see honestly
when we did this project I was like
sequel is gonna be on the rise because I
see it used in so many different types
of Java actually sequel was nowhere to
be found in even in the hot top hundred
drifting words well we did find though
as tableau came up a big one so data vis
in general was something that we saw in
our jobs over the last three years has
gone up in a big way and actually one of
the things I want to look at is to see
whether there are certain verticals
where that's actually happening but
across all data science jobs tableau is
doing well how do you put something that
came up out of our initial analysis
again in the top ten drifting words
which I was surprised about and what's
interesting is I threw in Spock because
I was like I'm kind of curious like is
it all of these sorts of processes or
just some of them and I think partly
because my theory is that AWS instances
have become much easier to deploy that
in most companies that sort of probably
corresponds to sort of like isn't
they'll remove the requirement for
Hadoop but Spock is still a steady and
then the last thing is and this was an
obvious one I mean he'll came up there
are very few jobs that require pearl but
pearl is actually frequently required in
combination with Python or in
combination with Java as an alternative
and actually you know it's dropped a lot
it wasn't starting off from a very high
beginning but it actually did drop a lot
and obviously Python steady so Python
actually didn't go up and contrast to
I've seen a whole lot of reports about
talking about Python and data science
jobs and Python in general I think we
have a lot of Python practitioners but I
don't think that it's
it's you know the number of jobs that
require it or going up that much and we
looked at a large corpus but we did see
were more subtle effects and actually
I'm super excited when I saw sequel in
my list from the large justice I was
like yes finally maybe they'll small one
made no sense whatsoever actually when
we go back and look at this if we look
at the number of jobs that require
sequel in general across old jobs as a
percentage of old jobs that we see is no
real difference in sequel demand but
what we do see is that in specific
verticals we're seeing increase in in
sequel requirements so in FPN a role so
these are finance roles in biz dev roles
with seeing an increase in sequel
requirements and in hey Charles and the
someone who works in the HR space for
all of the people who are still looking
for jobs like please go and join a chaud
departments they really need data
analysts they need people who know
sequel because this is a big area and
it's really important in terms of
opportunity and in terms of making sure
that these processes are fair because
then you need people who can work in
work with data in an effective way what
I found interesting is when we looked at
corollary so in FinTech roles or in
sales and marketing roles this is a
basically steady so it is coming up in
certain specific functions and the
reason why we had to do this analysis in
this way and looking at the number of
jobs at specific subtypes is because one
of the problems with the repo is that
some of this analysis is actually the
directionality and and what are the
nearest neighbors is somewhat hard to
extract so we're still working on trying
to get them to do that help us with that
so what I talked to you about today was
like a dynamic Bernoulli embedding it's
a subtype of a family of embeddings
called the exponential family but
embeddings and the reason why it's
called that is because it's thought to
be in the same way that in the same way
that regression is to generalize linear
models we have word tobacco's - this
family of embeddings that exponents sort
of that applies probabilistic context to
the data and I'm going to show you a
couple more examples and hopefully get
you excited about how you can use them
in some of your roles to end with the
first is we did all of this analysis
using Bernoulli embeddings Bernoulli
embeddings very
with binary data so we're basically
taking the word the data point is the
word and whether it exists or not and
the contexts are again
whether those words exist or not so
that's sort of the context of why it's
called exponential dynamic Bernoulli
embedding Hassanein burdens are another
type where you use count or ordinal data
and so what you would imagine and this
is very good for shopping-cart analysis
so you would take an item in a shopping
cart and then look at what other things
has that person bought and what is the
likelihood that they're going to buy
this one other thing and Gaussian
embeddings are especially useful for
continuous data so in this case I'm
showing you what would be a graph
database with nodes and edges and the
continuous data that I'm referring to as
a weight of an edge given the other
edges on the same node so for looking at
I think in this case this is a bit of a
mixed up example but if we're looking at
look at New York as an input how does
this interact with like given these
other contexts of other airports that
come in and out and what I think is
really interesting about paths on
embeddings as I sort of mentioned
earlier is it you know this if you think
about them in the word embedding space
you're like of course coffee goes close
with orange juice but if we abstract
these into a bunch of numbers and
categories right and say and which is
what the original group did and then you
know through shopping cart analysis and
this was only hundreds of thousands of
rows of shopping cart analysis so it's
actually quite small in terms of a
training set what they found was if you
convert that back into the key that it
was you find that the were like your
Yoplait yogurt finds other Yoplait
yogurt and chicken ramen finds other
types of ramen as well which I thought
was really fascinating in a totally
unsupervised way in a way where the
numbers had no relationship to the words
themselves and so I think that was
fascinating the last thing that I think
this and this is the last thing we're
going to talk about today is that this
lends itself to a couple of different
things the first is that by casting
these in this probabilistic context and
understanding the inner product you can
figure out things that have high energy
products so if we buy old Dutch potato
chips you have a high likelihood of
buying a beer and the same thing with if
you buy Lay's potato chips you're also
really likely to buy frozen pizza and it
also yields things that are rarely
bought together and so what you can see
here is again if you buy tide plus
detergent you're very unlikely to buy
cinnamon toast and that's kind of
interesting because it's like those are
two things that are rarely bought
together that's fine but it also yields
things that are substitutes so if you
buy one type of soup you're less likely
to buy another type of soup and so
that's actually a very interesting from
a you know ecommerce sort of side of
things really interesting it's also very
interesting from a web perspective so we
can find words that can be substitutes
or skills that can be substitutes and
skills that are alternatives and there's
something that we're very interested in
is as a company that's trying to tell
people maybe you should think of you
know these alternatives when you're
thinking of jobs so to conclude I'm
going to talk to you about the flavors
of static weren't embeddings and the
issue of corpuses and how important they
are in terms of when you're using
pre-trained embeddings in terms of
custom embedding models I talked about
some of the considerations you might
want to apply when you're considering
how to implement them I talked to I gave
you an example of a dynamic Bernoulli
embedding and how we use that to
understand data science skills and how
we show that things like using a smaller
corpus allowed you to figure out things
that were either there or not there
and using a large corpus gave us very
subtle detail about some of the skill
sets and the language as well as job
descriptions which I didn't have time to
talk about today and then the last thing
that I talked to you about was just
other families of this exponential
family of embeddings and the way that
you can use them and of course I talked
about dynamic Bernoulli embeddings in
the context of you know you cast the
years worth of them they're the
different types of embeddings across the
years right but you could actually use
that same intuition and do that across
categories and so create embeddings and
now case we're going to we're creating
embeddings based on junior roles versus
mid-level worlds versus senior roles and
how do those how do the way we talk
about skills along the seniority
spectrum change the way
they talked about in job descriptions so
with that I just wanted to thank you
[Music]